[Music]
everybody if I can't put it work
sure listen you guys gonna bin the night
right no you got a spin of bin yeah and
them [ __ ] kill your brother I've got
to empty the whole thing right guys
we'll take care of that tonight run down
on the [ __ ] make sure you kill one ml
of [ __ ] tonight make sure you didn't
do that whole thing no listen
your mother already buried your brother
don't have a very two sons gave me don't
come back with all your empty that's a
fact B [ __ ] let's go miles
yeah sure down now [ __ ] is this new I'm
your father your mommy just didn't tell
you
let's go miles let's go miles
let's go miles are you going her [ __ ]
was that they're bored yeah
somebody's birthday my daughter
Aldus you
she's [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
how you doing I'm the lyft driver that
you called to comigo right not a
girlfriend man oh credit card he was in
Bali come in there you go hmm
pay yourself whatever and uh give
yourself a nice step thank you
you're not gonna ask me if you got home
okay this is the point where usually I'd
give you a chance to do the right thing
but not tonight tonight I'm gonna need
your cameras cell phones anything you
might have used to record what you did
to her
you knocked on the wrong door tonight
pops
make sure she gets it Luka hey do it I'm
the driver you call to tickle me
girlfriend not a girlfriend that Oh
credit card was invalid give herself a
nice step I heard about these I've never
seen one before
yeah well that you have you're not gonna
ask me if she got home okay okay I'm
gonna need anything you might have used
to record what you did here tonight get
up you know a nice loser
my name is Amy give me a left hand it
was he stole a very good five stars for
Amy hey you should let somebody else do
this like Oh anybody you're right I
guess anybody could do it but nobody
does mouth it's great you're helping all
these random people stay off the radar
they killed my friend
so I'm gonna kill each and every one of
them the only disappointment is that I
only get to do it once it's mistake to
go to war with him they're highly
trained father your mommy just didn't
tell you on your stability if you're
lucky they'll give you the opportunity
to do the right thing this ain't one of
those times
well not one one
why are you Jackie Chan you got fat Dave
I went to your funeral breathe a long
time over you Susan she knew I was your
partner for seven years back I never
kept anything from you I'm sorry life
got dark ever talk to the boys no not
for years hell of a team we were right
should make the building do that it's
what they supposed to do
that's the hole do and will do or two
different things miles you know they got
a they got painting companies around
here I know they charge six seven
hundred dollars to do the job I know
rats
[Applause]
don't do this for 350 you yeah I'm an
artist man I go to bridge new boss you
know I got a special talent yes you do
and it takes talent to make money but it
takes brains to keep it mouth yeah well
no here make your money man show up
money miles a short money I'll tell you
what 350 is a little high but I
appreciate off first time no no no long
time ago different life
now you come back yes I'm looking for
something you can find whatever they
wish in talking about a man who
kidnapped a little girl from her
American mother will not be looking for
such a man will be dangerous for you men
like him with a rabid I'm the only
friend it's great you helping all these
random people and everything it stay off
the radar something happened to one of
ours
so I'm obligated to look into them
don't you ever type oh I am just like
your dead
[Music]
yeah it's a matter
[Music]
they knew what floor she was off
we're tying up loose ends exactly party
over seven years max mistake to go to
war with him is no
they're going to war with me
whoever did this of all chart skillsets
with the agency family it was a Star
Trek pretty good well not one one coat
they killed my friends
so I'm gonna kill each and every one of
them and let me disappoint me is that
only I get to do it once
[Music]
senior care and all those books around I
figured you for some kind of teacher
from a high level paid for an assassin
[Music]